i mean the contrast between the reports
we've seen on your program this morning
the images that we have seen in the
newspapers of military personnel
carrying children to safety we know that
british diplomatic staff are literally
handwriting visa applications on the
tarmac at kabul airport they're
answering the call but the foreign
secretary and now it transpires his
deputy couldn't even be bothered to make
a call because he was on holiday i think
that is unconscionable and unforgivable
this debate around what difference it
may or may not have made well it's all
speculative now because it didn't happen
it certainly wouldn't have done any harm
and for the foreign secretary to be
missing an action during this crisis
i think is unforgivable and i think his
position is untenable
but the argument being made
not necessarily about why he personally
wouldn't make the phone call because the
argument being made generally is that is
it everyone from the uk to the united
states and other nato allies were
blindsided by the speed in which this
happened and the speed in which kabul
fell
what has the foreign secretary been
doing for the last 18 months you know
after
doha and the withdrawal that was
announced we knew that this day was
coming the uk charged the g7 it's a
leading member of nato it has a un
security council seat those are all
within the job remit of the foreign
secretary to use whatever labor she can
i'll give you an example of this in
april the government set up a scheme to
help
afghans who had worked with the british
to apply for refugee status there are
seven thousand of those people but only
two thousand have been processed and
that's why we're seeing the chaotic
scenes at kabul airport and with the
government itself says that not everyone
will get out that is an admission of
failure of strategy over the last 18
months and now of course it's being left
to those on the ground doing their very
best working really hard from military
personnel through the diplomatic staff
to try and do what they can
operationally to mitigate the disaster
that has been a complete absence of any
strategy to prepare for this day over
the last 18 months i mean
what would you like to see happen now
because look the reality is and whatever
political points
you either want to or need to be made
with this we are where we are and we're
talking about people's lives here so
it's about looking forward now isn't it
in the immediate term so what do you
want to see happen now
well that's absolutely the priority to
get british nationals to safety
and then
others as we can that has got to be the
focus of everyone and again i commend
and pay tribute to those working so hard
on the ground to make that happen
there are concerns i think about the
access to the airport i think there are
worries as well about not the uk i
understand but some other countries
where planes have been leaving that are
virtually empty so there needs to be no
a diplomatic effort to ensure that we
working with our allies do as much as we
can over the coming days but then
in a further and in a wider context
we need to and we have a duty to as
kirsten armor the leader of the labour
party said in the comments this week to
see that our friends are all right we
can't abandon these people we can't
abandon those who worked
with us and for us in afghanistan we
can't abandon
the women in prominent positions in
public life there are the judges the
members of the afghan parliament
we need to have a full and comprehensive
security assessment about the
consequences of the collapse of the
afghan government and its system and the
taliban taking power and what impact
that will have
on us here in the uk those are all
things that need to happen urgently and
britain given its position in the world
should be leading those efforts it's not
good enough to criticize the uas
administration it's not good enough for
the foreign secretary to say not make of
not my responsibility the prime minister
himself should now intervene he should
corral all of our allies through nato
working through the u.n security council
and in the chairmanship of the g7 to get
an international agreement about what
we're going to do in terms of refugees
and how we're going to approach uh the
government uh that is taking power in
afghanistan i mean you talk about not
abandoning our friends
but what what do we actually do if you
get even if we got out all the people
that you talked about what do we then do
in dealing with afghanistan do we do we
deal with with the taliban on on a
proper diplomatic in a proper diplomatic
way do we do we try to assert any any
political force on them do we do we have
maintain an armed presence there i mean
ideally what would you like to see
look i think the first thing to say is
that these are all questions that we've
known we're going to have to be answered
for the last 18 months and it seems that
not only have the uk government but the
international community has failed to
address any of them i think in terms of
what the taliban does we will have to
judge them by
their actions clearly over the next
number of days there is a practical
element to ensuring that we get as many
people out as possible and if the
taliban are surrounding the airport then
there will need to be some engagement
with them at ground level as our
military commanders there have already
said is taking place to ensure that we
can do that as quickly as possible
but then i think we and the west needs
to regroup and needs to focus and needs
to look very carefully at the strategy
towards afghanistan and it needs to be a
united approach we need to ensure that
organizations like the international
monetary fund play its part in terms of
it having the afghan
reserves and i think we also need to
look at aid about where that goes and
about how that is deployed we of course
have to avoid
any further humanitarian catastrophe and
crisis and any addition to the awful
heartbreaking scenes that we've seen but
we can't allow the taliban having
seized some of the levers of power that
it has already to be given any cover by
the international community until we've
been able to make a full on proper
assessment of just what this new regime
is doing